>>> THESE DAYS, IT'S HARD NOT TO
FEEL STRESSED OUT AND
OVERWHELMED.
SURE, TRUMP GOT INDICTED, BUT
NOW EVERYONE SAYS THE CASE
AGAINST HIM IS WEAK AND THAT
HE'LL NEVER SERVE ANY JAIL TIME.
AS SOMEONE WHOSE ENTIRE
PERSONALITY IS HATING DONALD
TRUMP, YOU NEED MORE.
YOU NEED TO FEEL CALM AND
REASSURED.
YOU NEED THE NEWEST MEDITATION
APP.
CNZ.
NEW DETAILS FROM TRUMP'S ARREST,
FEATURING YOUR FAVORITE CNN
ANCHORS.
>> HE'S THE FIRST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TO EVER BE INDICTED.
THIS IS TRULY A HISTORIC AND
HUMILIATING MOMENT.
>> TRUMP IS A BRAD, DEFEATED
MAN.
THEY MADE HIM COME FROM FLORIDA
WHERE IT'S 80 DEGREES TO NEW
YORK WHERE IT'S ONLY 60 DEGREES.
HOW DEPRESSING.
>> HIS MOTOR CADE WASN'T THAT
BIG.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BIGGER,
BUT IT WAS SO SMALL.
>> DONALD WAS ALL ALONE, NO
FAMILY OR FRIENDS TO SUPPORT
HIM.
I SHOULDN'T SAY THIS AS A
JOURNALIST, BUT THAT A LOSER.
>> THAT NEW YORK TIMES REPORTER
MAGGIE HABERMAN SOOTH YOU TO
SLEEP.
>> THAT IS A NIGHTMARE, AND HE'S
REALLY FREAKING OUT BECAUSE NOW
HE KNOWS THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES.
>> YOU CAN ALSO LISTEN TO CLIPS
OF TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
SPIRALING.
>> PLEASE, DONALD J. TRUMP IS AN
INNOCENT MAN AND HE NEEDS YOUR
HELP.
SEND HIM ALL YOUR MONEY TODAY AT
DON'T J. TRUMP RU/FUND RAISING
SCAM.GUILTY.
>> HIS COURT APPEARANCE WON'T BE
UNTIL AT LEAST DECEMBER.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE A WHOLE
LIST OF TRUMP INDICTMENT ASR.
>> CAN YOU HEAR HIM GETTING
FINGERPRINTED, AND THE DA
OPENING HIS BIG LEATHER
BRIEFCASE, AND A LITTLE GAVEL
FROM THE JUDGE.
I WONDER IF HE'LL EVEN HEAR HAND
CUFFS.
>> WITH ADDITIONAL IN-APP
PURCHASES LIKE AUDIO E RAT KA OF
ALVIN BRAGG READING ALL 40
FELONY ACCOUNTS.
>> COUNT ONE, FALSIFYING
BUSINESS RECORDS IN THE FIRST
DEGREE.
COUNT TWO, FALSIFYING BUSINESS
RECORDS IN THE FIRST DEGREE.
COUNT THREE, FALSIFYING --
>> YOU WAITED SEVEN YEARS FOR
THIS INDICTMENT, AND YOU WANT
EVERY DELICIOUS DETAIL.
>>, WHAT ETHNICITY IS TRUMP'S
JUDGE AGAIN?
>> HISPANIC.